I always thought that politics is a bit
like volleyball you can only score
points in your own serve and it's
definitely not admin bad serve at the
moment that every one man wants a poll
showing just how much contempt a public
hold open about it so you've heard the
guys you know tiempo which has minimum
having the lower personal ratings for
Nick Clegg which is alarming for the
Labour leader then you've got the
Evening Standard poll today showing that
49 percent of voters want Labour's
change leader before the next election
and the remarkable thing about that poll
is that even on labour voters that
number is above 40 percent I think the
real warrior mother market is that when
he wants to talk he wants to make that
selection a battle of ideas and talk
about policy but he can't cut through
the personality question of personality
politics and the really war anything for
labour is it's personal I think not
getting worse the more the public zfm
are they stuck with millibar now do you
think yeah and I also think that the
Potters personality is is not to change
leaders if this would Lib Dems bother
perhaps who knows what happened with the
Lib Dems but labour leaders think tend
to go unless they die and I don't think
there's much lose an election either I
don't think that's going to happen to
Miliband in the next few months no I
think it will work either but also he he
can come in this close to an election
and organize the party because actually
if you had the the instability of no
leader and a leadership election you
don't have all these factions who are
saying oh we shouldn't have sent a we
shouldn't have states it at least you've
got a fraction you can recognize at the
road which is the ante minute battle
faction which is still quite small
within the party
because he works really hard with his
back benches if you'd oppose Miliband
and bought someone else if you'd have
civil war will we stop another cabinet
I mean what you will see more more
changes I mean that they are they are
quite clear but after Cameron has done
his reshuffle there will be a label
reshuffle and look well that make you
didn't have difference too early I think
you will see him trying to present
people who look like a change from the
past there the government's on TV things
have better media performance there's a
constant critic and the critique in EMA
dad's office at the shadow cabinet don't
work or not but they aren't out there
putting the hard yards and so I think
people who are energetic have got a very
good honest which other that some of the
the most frustrated with looks safest so
leaving aside their bullets who is a
conundrum himself if at Cooper is
another cat Shadow Cabinet minister who
was consistently underperforming who
even though threes amazing impressive
Home Secretary in that Cooper really
helps to reason may by learning her get
away with a great deal of stuff she's
not particularly known for being
proactive
ticking wet in terms of pitching stories
to journalists and there is frustration
in Miliband's team about her and but can
you move her and can you move these big
beasts who aren't performing that I know
Miliband's team are very impressed
people I trust from Hans Reichel Ruiz
even actually first Muhammed perform
particularly well recently in the
Collins his performance of education
questions on Monday was not great but
but you can move those guys and promote
them but can you get rid of the big
people who have sort of been blocking
basically politically